Buongiorno ragazzi miei sono in nella
mia stanza d'albergo qua a Tokyo e mi
sono svegliato con una sorpresa una
sorpresa un po' strana perché davanti
alla porta della mia stanza ho trovato
questo
invitation 22 maggio 2023 ragazzi e oggi
è proprio Nintendo che mi ha invitato a
un evento Segreto e quindi oggi andiamo
a scoprire che cos'è Finalmente sono
gasatissimo ragazzi non avete la minima
e ho dormito 4 ore perché sono un jet
laggato ma non me ne frega niente Sono
veramente troppo preso bene
Finalmente posso dirvi tutto finalmente
posso dirvi tutto tutto nessuno sa il
perché io sia tornato in Giappone dopo
neanche un mese che c'è lo Stato perché
sono tornati in Giappone oggi ve lo
posso dire Nintendo ma non so se
conoscete Nintendo è quella che fa
quello che fa le cose belle
Nintendo mi manda un messaggio questo
messaggio Nintendo me lo manda quando io
sono in Giappone ancora quindi quando
nel viaggio prima mi chiamava Ti
andrebbe di tornare in Giappone e io
c'è un progetto segreto del quale non
possiamo dirti nulla però ci fai sapere
se ti va di farlo Io sì non me ne non so
cosa si Esso sono tornato in Giappone
con Nintendo hanno scelto un Creator per
nazionalità Quindi io ero ehm portavoce
italiano sostanzialmente per presentare
un nuovo titolo Nintendo ho preparato
questi tre video sono gasatissimo avete
ideavamo quindi ragazzi adesso
scopriremo perché siamo qua Eh niente
Let's go Grazie Lorenzo a questo era un
video di 5 secondi Beh Bene bene Non è
prolisso non è bravo Lorenzo bravo
Questa è la clip 3 è entrata dentro la
sala dove hanno annunciato che è questo
3 2 1
Ok Questi erano i ragazzi con cui sono
andato per altri youtuber influencer
creators tutti quanti Eccomi qua sono
qua Io se mi conoscete io non mi ero
messo d'accordo con lui eh per vestirmi
perché siamo vestiti uguali Non lo so
Ottima scelta di outfit Siamo passati
questa stanza gigante con dei tappeti
Grazie di inquadratura Bene bene bene
grazie Il mio sorriso deve spaccare la
camera bella sei contenta mamma loro
erano gli youtuber giapponese proprio
cioè ho fatto amicizia sono
simpaticissimi qua c'è il presentatore
in tutto ciò perché per presentare cioè
c'è lui
Everybody want you Suits questo Ragazzi
è il gioco che hanno presentato
Everybody one two switch non so se avete
presente che cos'è io io qua stavo ero
ero in estasi non avete idea di quello
che state per vedere Let's go hanno
fatto due team Ok Io ero in questo team
qua a destra e hanno scritto anche il
mio nome molto bene che è
particolarmente rara una cosa
Prima di ciò che sono i palloni due
squadre si devono sfidare
4 verso 4 a determinate sfide qua la
sfida consiste nel chi gonfia di più il
pallone ma non deve esplodere perché se
esplode si è squalificati come quello
che è successo adesso ma adesso tocca a
noi per esempio adesso ci sono io che
gonfio il pallone Guarda che tecnica di
qua che cos'è qua sei il criceto Ma
cos'è magari ridicolo Guarda stavo
facendo calcoli matematici
algebrici per capire chi fosse il più
grande attenzione
[Applauso]
Non mi ricordo chi ha vinto hanno vinto
loro Porca vacca ragazzi hanno vinto
loro era la precisione del
99,9%, Cioè ma neanche se vai lì col
goniometro riesci a fare 1-1 Quindi
visto che siamo stati forti ci hanno
fatto giocare continuamente io Grazie di
aver fatto la stretta su come muovo le
mani Ragazzi grazie che si vede proprio
che so soffrendo come un animale tutto
questo non ha senso raga abbiamo vinto
ero io che stavo giocando eh quindi ho
vinto Ho vinto io in particolare Quindi
va bene la prima sfida raga abbiamo
vinto Noi intanto pazzesca sta cosa
nell'outfit non mi entra in testa
ragazzi siamo vestiti uguali Ma com'è
possibile Abbiamo vinto noi non si non
mi potete e niente ragazzi Anche se la
tecnica faceva schifo sono stati
fortissimi secondo il gioco Ragazzi
allora consiste nel correre e passare il
joycon quando si finisce di correre alla
persona davanti Ok qua hanno mixato un
po' le squadre perché dopo Entro anche
io insomma è impossibile fare una corsa
decente sul posto però è molto cringe
questa cosa molto cringe e ce Favij
dentro la terza Favij Eccolo eccolo Mi
sono tolto Mi sono tolto la la
giacchetta di jeans Perché giustamente è
l'agonismo Eccolo vai questa vedrete io
ero contro di lui ma ho vinto io ho
vinto io la mia parte l'ho fatta la mia
parte l'ho fatta lui è arrivato dopo
quindi tre c'era il ragazzo che non si è
tolto la giacchetta come me però eh E
comunque è stato molto bravo
lui si chiama Ray bacon ragazzi è
spagnolo molto bravo anche lui eh Kick
the PJ in testa inglesi che provano a
arrivare al traguardo prima attenzione
Kid dpg
e ce la fa e ce la fanno ce la fanno
Team Europa contro japa Comunque ragazzi
contro il Giappone siamo fortissimi Non
so perché cioè è una forza incredibile
adesso Sono molto orgogliosa la mia
squadra ma sono stati molto bravi e
adesso arrivano le Chicche aggiuntive
ragazzi perché qua con il quadni
potevamo partecipare alla partita
scannerizzandola col nostro telefono
quindi il telefono diventava tutti gli
effetti un gioco Eccolo
Ma perché quando scannerizzi puoi
generare la partita facendoti una foto
con lo smartphone io ho fatto questa
foto va bene a lui è diventato un
cavallo il presentatore è un cavallo con
una giga carota nella tasca ma non è una
cosa su cui soffermarci ragazzi perché
le stranezze arrivano adesso Everybody
One switch può essere giocato da un
totale di
100 giocatori questa cosa è incredibile
Dietro quella tenda c'erano altre
persone c'è un altro 84 persone che
hanno visto me correre in questo modo
invece vi rendete conto ero qua Ero
scioccato da questa scioccato non ce la
potevo fare dopodiché abbiamo iniziato
abbiamo startato la competizione vera e
propria con 100 persone e qua c'è una
Madonna incredibile Questa cosa ragazzi
Qua c'è una io che parlo con piger che
non so effettivamente Come si fanno le
cose semplici questo gioco consiste nel
girare attorno alla qui a questo tavolo
rosso che vedete è il momento in cui si
ferma la musica ci si deve accovacciare
per terra è tipo il gioco della sedia
quando girate con la musica e poi
tolgono la sedia è la stessa cosa
vengono eliminati quelli più lenti a
fare questa cosa Quindi chi si abbassa
più lentamente Io vedete che sono qua
che corro come un
[Applauso]
[Musica]
appena si ferma la musica ci si
accovaccia attenzione
Dai perché sono partito bene Sono
partito bene
[Musica]
quanto tempo per abbassarti Favij Mamma
mia Ma come si fa a essere così scarsi
sono ve lo dico sono state eliminate
Ragazzi ve lo dico io ho fatto schifo e
si parte di nuovo con me che guardo la
sfida invece di giocarla perché sono
stato eliminato Forza Italia mandateme
quando c'era da presentarci perché sono
forte vedete che me la cavo eh non è che
Ma chi ha vinto questa gara è
incredibile tra tutti quanti
partecipanti questa Egg Egg magico Egg
che è un fenomeno Ed eccoci qua tutti
incolonnati da una parte 50 Player
dall'altra 50 Player è ehm bisognava
giocare di squadra ma qual era il gioco
Ragazzi ve lo dico io adesso vi faccio
vedere ed era una cosa Eh adesso si
parte Ah no non era l'ultimo questo
Scusatemi il penultimo il penultimo
gioco Eccoci qua che saltiamo Io sono
molto a mio agio si vede però guarda che
salti ragazzi guarda che salto a saltare
me la cavo eh a saltare me la cavo
minuto e infatti siamo stati ognuno di
noi come non detto raga facciamo cagare
ragazzi l'atletica io non c'ho gazzella
sono arrivato anche un buon punto Non mi
rompete le scatole il gioco finale è
incredibile
non grigiate non grigiate Ragazzi vi
spiego in cosa consiste questa cosa
ragazzi Favij Keep the Beat perché stavo
facendo ovviamente tutto male bisogna
fare questa cosa nel uh ah uh ah per
evocare richiamare degli alieni vedete
sono molto esperti in questo mi hanno
inquadrato perché per pena del cameraman
è andato su di me giustamente è andato
su di me e adesso si vede la scena in
cui noi riusciamo a evocare gli alieni
rispetto all'altra squadra che non ci è
riuscita è lo schermo come potete vedere
lo schermo Gli alieni sono arrivati e
abbiamo vinto noi con che con Guarda che
esultanza perché cioè fai tutto male fa
schifo tutto ma chi vince questa vince
tutto quindi io come sempre sulle cose
definitive sono bravo faccio cagare in
tutto il resto Però vabbè Ah abbiamo
rifatto l'abbiamo rifatto sta abbiamo
fatto due volte vero mi sono dimenticato
l'abbiamo fatta due volte Scusatemi
Scusate leva quella finale era la
semifinale ma comunque l'abbiamo fatta
due volte e visto che abbiamo vinto la
prima possiamo non seconda come vedete
io carico a molla come sempre perché io
oggi veramente devo stravincere sennò
non sono contento Io ci sono io ci sono
e gioco per vincere guardalo guarda
anche pidgey è anche pidgey siamo in due
là ragazzi eh facciamo in due che ci
crediamo Eh quindi fa tutto perché la
squadra l'ha trascinata Ci vuole un
capitano i ragazzi di destra qua sono
molto più carichi e si vede Guarda gli
alieni come ci apprezzano si
avvicinavano e si allontanavano allo
stesso tempo è stato incredibile non
capivano bene gli alieni se scendere o
meno secondo me non volevano scendere
hanno detto No ragazzi Io sto pianeta
non ci vogliamo stare però vabbè
Eccola
[Applauso]
il vincitore Come si congratulano
bellissimo ragazzi bravissimi braccola
il sorriso di un vincente ragazzi il
sorriso di un vincente Ovviamente io io
ho fatto del mio meglio applauso di
consolazione per la squadra perdente Ma
la squadra che vince è quella che conta
non vedo l'ora che arrivi ragazzi che
esca perché lo voglio giocare non solo
con i miei amici ma voglio invitare 100
persone in casa mia e giocare in 100 lo
voglio fare
Eccoci qua Eh ragazzi per i vincitori
ovviamente no ma sentiamo cosa da dirci
il nostro Favij post partita diccelo
Favij dice raga Sono ancora distrutto
dalla corsa che abbiamo fatto Beh si
vede Si vede c'è che ho fatto solo tu
hai fatta però abbiamo vinto
un ragazzo felice Quindi ragazzi Questa
era il progetto segreto per cui sono
andato in Giappone si chiama Everybody
one two switch Se volete in 100 persone
possiamo giocarlo appena esce venite a
casa mia che c'è spazio lo giochiamo ma
non è finita qua Ragazzi c'è un altro
video segreto che uscirà la prossima
settimana non si tratta di un videogioco
si tratta sempre di qualcosa legato al
Nintendo forse più scaltri di voi
avranno capito ragazzi Non vi posso dire
niente Mi piace darvi sulle spine ma
spero che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto lasciate un
commento e un mi piace se lo sauriti
scrivete E noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video Non mancate perché è una
roba sempre top secret che vi assicuro
merita bella ragazzi